they'll take their swings off 27 year
old john means
it was a rough start
of the season for john means but he has
returned to that all-star form that he
showed last year in the first half of
the season his last two times out he's
been outstanding against the new york
mets it was a quality start six innings
pitch one run he allowed then against
the yankees on the road as well six
innings pitch five hits one run allowed
it he has really turned his season
around
satsugo started the scoring for the
raise last night he hit a solo homer in
the third inning
one-two pitch
got him looking
two down
gets kevin smith to the plate
and down on strikes goes kevin smith so
a couple of strikeouts for john mean
ray's retired orioles coming to bat no
score here's nunez
one down
runners at second and third
little looper that'll fall in with the
infield in
might score two
here comes hayes rushing to the plate no
play and it's a two rbi base hit for
renato nunez
take advantage of the situation get the
bat on the ball and good things can
happen
it wasn't a screaming line drive but
it's a two-run rbi base hit for nunez
well pulling the infield in helped the
raise against mount castle right it
saved the run but this hurt right here
for william thomas to lead off
the second here for the raise
went chasing then down goes adamus third
strikeout for john means
yeah third punch out in a row
now it's nate lowe and there's another
strikeout so four straight punch outs as
low goes down swinging hunter renfro
02 and he threw it by him so he strikes
out the side
john means business five straight
strikeouts orioles up two nothing
cenino's full count now
got him and that's six straight
strikeouts zanino looking and john means
just dotting the eye right on the
outside corner
[Music]
here's another one wendell looking seven
straight strikeouts for john means and
that just matched the club record
seven consecutive strikeouts
and there's a base hit to end the k
street 50 pitches now that's one thing
about those strikeouts they'll run that
pitch count up
got him
second time satsugo has gone down
looking and the eight strikeout sets a
career high for john means who is
normally not a strikeout pitcher but he
is painting the outside part of the
plate down in a way as good as you can
do it and there's where severino's set
up and that's exactly where the ball is
delivered again this is kevin smith
and he got him a little
little slow breaking ball right pitch
number 13
and strikeout number nine
there's a high fly ball well tagged in
the deep center gone into the bullpen to
the left of the 410 marker and adamus
with his seventh home run of the year
will get the raise on the board to make
it a two-to-one game well that's what
the rays are gonna have to do means has
not made many mistakes and but he's not
gonna be perfect you know they're gonna
be some pitches left out over the plate
when they are you must capitalize and
that's what really did right there only
the second hit for the raise nate lowe
struck out in the second comes the 1-2
pitch got him strikeout number 10 struck
out the side 2-2 count to mike cenino
he goes
strikeout 11 with each strikeout now
john means establishes a career high
john means back out for the sixth inning
got him another strikeout for john means
he mows him down number 12. this was on
that bigger of the two breaking balls
the curve ball he's had a good one today
look at the depth on that one so it
starts well above the waist
of sutsugo by the time it gets all the
way to home place see sugo's front side
leave bow when your front side leaves
you fly open that front shoulder you got
no chance of hitting something on the
outside part of the plate and there's
his 12th strikeout one strike pitch to
smith popped up right side of the
infield alberto comes all the way over
and makes the grab two down that might
be it yeah willie adams coming to the
plate he's got the only run the solo
home run
dylan tate appears to be loose and ready
to go in that oriole bullpen an
outstanding effort by john means today
well the fans might not be able to tip
the hat but you and i can do it right
what an effort from john means
12 strikeouts
in five and two third innings orioles
lead 2-1
this is brandon lau
rips and that's the ball game the line
drive to mount castle and the orioles
get a win in this series and end the
regular season with a 2-1 win what a
great day on the mound for the orioles
john means with his 12 k's tate
harvey and valdez and the birds get one
in the win column 2-1 the final score